I want to eat.
Paul,
if you don't mind just telling me about it,
what you had for breakfast this morning
as a soundcheck,
so uncheck breakfast coffin.
[inaudible].
Thank you for supporting the sponsors of this show,
99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for all things graphic design related.
Go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim to see the projects that I've put up,
including the mock ups and drafts of the book cover for the four hour body.
As always,
you can subscribe to this podcast on iTunes and you can find all of the links
and resources from this episode as well as every other episode by going to four
hour work week.com forward slash podcast spell it all out or you can go to four
hour work week.com and just click on podcast feedback.
If you have feedback,
I would love your thoughts,
anything at all who you'd like to see on this show,
Ping me on Twitter at [inaudible].
That's twitter.com forward slash t f e R R I s s or on facebook@facebook.com
forward slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two s's.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show where
of course I try to deconstruct world class performers,
whether they be billionaire investor is chess,
prodigies,
athletes and everything in between to pull apart,
tease out the tactics and tools and resources that you can use and this episode
was a real treat.
I had so much fun with this.
It was easily one of the most enlightening and lucid conversations about
physical training I've ever had and we covered everything,
meaning strength,
flexibility,
endurance and beyond.
And my guest is none other than Pavel Tsatsouline and yes,
that is how you say it.
He is chairman of strong first inc and was born in minx.
Not Thinks Minsk.
I always have so much trouble saying that.
Not that I say at that much.
USSR,
former USSR,
which is now part of Baylor Russ in the 1980s he was a physical training
instructor for [inaudible].
That's also another one I want to miss pronounce always.
It's not Spetsnaz Spit Nas,
the elite Soviet special forces units.
Pablo is now a subject matter expert to the u s Marine Corps,
US secret service and the US Navy seals and he has also perhaps you know this or
not,
he is widely credited with introducing the Kettlebell to the United States,
the ubiquitous kettle bell,
which is called kettle ball by almost everyone.
Maybe that should be changed to make things easier.
In any case,
over the last several years,
Pablo has become a friend of mine.
I'm honored to call him a friend and his input was critical to the success and
many of the experiments of the four hour body,
whether you have heard of him or not,
stick with this interview prepared to have your mind blown and I really don't
say that lightly.
You are going to enjoy this and that you will have a lot to take notes on and
they're all of course,
be tons in the show notes@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash podcast but without
further ado,
here we go.
Please meet Pavel Tsatsouline.
Pavel,
welcome to the show.
I'm so thrilled to have you.
And I thought we would start with the,
the answer to a question that I ask all of my guests,
which is how do you pronounce your name properly?
Uh,
bubble.
So insulin,
it's hot.
Sulan and,
and you'd mentioned before we came on what you tell people at Starbucks if you
order a coffee in the end,
what does that it just has to be Pablo Pablo.
There was no other way
and I uh,
I've really admired your work and the expertise and also just your method of
teaching quite frankly for so many years.
And I was having trouble piecing together how we first came in contact.
Of course,
I was well aware of your work prior to us having us having any direct contact.
But how,
do you recall how we,
how we came to know each other?
Yes,
I do it Tim.
Uh,
as you,
I'm a big fan of simplicity in my life and different aspects of my life.
And a four hour work week really resonated with me.
And at that point I remember writing an article and I entitled the,
an Article Ferris Bueller's Day,
the gym.
Okay.
And I sent you that article.
I submitted it for him,
Blah.
That's right.
Okay.
And that,
that,
that really set a cascade of events in motion.
And I became very,
very fascinated.
I mean,
of course,
like a lot of people,
I think I was initially exposed to you as the strength trainer who,
who used the word comrade at a lot and really hadn't,
hadn't delved into a lot of the details,
uh,
of your strength training specifically,
which will of course get into.
And I guess there are two questions I'd love to ask,
but the first is,
uh,
what do people consider you,
the people who know you well,
what do they consider you world class at
Tim?
I have been able to take very complex subjects,
take them apart and put them back together in a manner that's very simple,
that can be delivered to regular people without losing the essence of what
these,
uh,
of the systems.
So I'm talking about specifically serious strength.
I'm talking about both programming and I'm talking about what I would refer to
as a divided language of strengths.
And could you explain for people who are perhaps not,
uh,
not inductees into the world of strength training yet?
What do you mean by programming?
Programming,
planning your training.
You go from a to B,
you want to add 50 pounds to deadlift.
This is what you do.
And unfortunately the world of programming is very confused.
While the whole world of fitness is very confused and again,
at what I attempt to do is to bring principle based training.
So when you understand the principles,
applications are,
many applications are easy,
right?
And I,
I think that's where I feel such a,
such a degree of,
of kinship with what you tried to do with these subjects.
Because of course,
whether I succeed or fail and sometimes they do both,
uh,
I,
that's very much what I try to deal with.
The subjects that I tend to obsess on.
And for,
for those who are familiar with your background,
you've worked with many different types of elite athletes and also special
forces and so on.
Uh,
would you mind just giving a little bit of background on your,
um,
your bonafide,
so to speak,
some of your,
your,
your background as it relates to,
to training?
I'm sure.
Fine.
I used to be a PT training instructor,
physical training instructor force beds,
Oz,
uh,
sort a special courses.
And my education is in sports science and uh,
I did over the years trained a number of,
uh,
high end units in the West.
I've been a subject matter to a US Marine Corps,
to the US secret service,
uh,
Jews,
navy seals and others.
And uh,
my methods are used,
uh,
officially by some very high end,
military and counter terrorist units into countries that are main allies of the
United States.
What I do,
pardon me?
Oh,
I'm sorry.
No,
I was just,
uh,
my,
my brain erupted with something nonsensical.
Please continue.
So,
so what I do is I take methods that perform very well in very rugged
environments and I take this methods and I apply it to other environments.
So if somebody decides I just wanted to change my life,
I went to get stronger.
I want to have a better game of tennis.
I want to succeed in a given sport.
I take these same methods that have been tested by operators at war,
and I bring these people the same methods.
And uh,
just to,
to,
to drill into that because I've seen the many,
I'm sure at this point,
thousands of photographs that are sent to you by deployed troops overseas or
people in special forces,
uh,
of their kettle bells or,
or they're,
they're,
uh,
they're rigged.
They're rigged gyms with know,
sort of makeshift pull up bars and whatnot.
What,
what is it that you have to keep mind when you're designing or why have,
why have your methods had such appeal for a elite military?
What are the things that you've considered perhaps at other people have not for
those types of trainees?
Well,
and Plutarch who said thousands of years ago that the training of a soldier and
the training of an athlete is radically different.
That I'd athlete has the luxury of a pampered lifestyle and,
uh,
the soldier doesn't.
So this is pretty much the difference.
So what you want to do is you want to build the training that'd becomes in the
wards or one of my favorite authors did they seem Taleb antifragile is that type
of trading training does it thrives on very harsh environment that's really
robust in those different environments.
And uh,
that's pretty much the difference.
How do we do that?
We have to strip all the nonessentials down pretty much what you do in your work
with different,
uh,
with business,
with lifestyle and so on.
And once we get down to the things that really matter and we apply them,
then everything's out in the big towns.
Very simple.
Have you spent any time with,
uh,
Nasim?
No,
I have not.
I'm looking forward to,
Oh,
I should,
uh,
I should introduce you guys at some point.
He's,
he's exactly what you see is what you get if you've read his books.
And I think you guys would really hit it off.
Uh,
the,
uh,
you know,
what you just said brought to mind,
uh,
a conversation that I had with a friend of mine who was formerly navy seal and
now he's doing things that he can't tell me about,
not that he could tell me much about what he did before,
but,
uh,
he and actually,
not to be named,
but I now that now that I think of it,
you introduced us.
Uh,
so let's call him victor.
Victor.
Yes.
Amazing guy.
And uh,
victor is,
is the most efficient trash compactor I've ever seen in my life.
He,
he can eat anything and make fuel out of it.
And he was,
uh,
he was criticizing it in a very good natured way.
Some of his colleagues,
cause he said,
well,
you know,
some of the guys that I,
that I work with out in the field,
you know,
some of them are the bodybuilder types and they get really grumpy if they can't
have their protein shake every two or three hours.
And he's said,
I view it as a real competitive and practical advantage that I can,
I can consume anything.
And then go for a 30 40 50 mile run.
Well and victor 40 strengths also.
That gentleman is exceptional both in his strengths and he's and Doris budge for
his strengths.
He relies on the nervous system,
not so much in the muscle to,
and again,
that's what's so there's lots of different,
you can if you look at or a typical person and how do we get him stronger.
Let's say that you have a four cylinder engine and what the person would do is
they would make that,
you know,
six cylinder engine,
but before you were firing in two and now you're firing in three.
But if instead you do is you learn to fire on all four.
So there are ways of training your nervous system to engage your capacity so
much more fully.
And if you look at high level performers at light body weight in some fields,
let's say a very high level martial artists,
somebody very skinny,
breaking a stack of boards or very skinny guy like landmark and dead lifting
five times his body weight.
So this is so much about the concentration of mental force.
And for your listeners,
I could give a very simple example how you can use,
you can do that.
Then your gym,
let's say that you performed,
tried for the simplest exercise possible,
try it with a dumbbell curl or a barbell curl because I know your sissies out
there.
You'll do that and so let's say that you were going through your curls and
things are suddenly started to get tougher so when these suddenly start to get
tougher,
I wouldn't you to just crush the dumbbell or the barbell or the kettle bell,
whatever it is that you're currently just white knuckle,
white knuckled pressure and which you will see is you're going to definitely
going to be able to get several more repetitions out and I'm going to give you
two more techniques in addition,
once you have practiced that,
then on the next set,
in addition to crushing the bar and the way up,
also contract your glutes as tight as possible.
Like somebody going to kick you in the bud very,
very tight.
So you just like crunch,
you will not.
And at the same time tighten your abs as if somebody is going to kick you,
which you know,
somebody might.
So if you do that,
if you do these three things,
if you can track your glutes,
contract,
your abs,
your grip,
everything that you do,
absolutely everything is going to be greatly amplified.
And this is just a small example of the skills of strengths that I do teach.
And we're going to,
we're going to dig really deeply into this because I have personally reached a
point where I want to return to the training of a,
an athlete who's trying to optimize relative strength as opposed to just packing
on slabs and pounds of muscle.
Uh,
which,
uh,
quite frankly,
just my frame and my joints and my,
my entire system is,
is,
is finding a aggravating to sustain just the,
the,
the fulltime eating and other bull diabetes.
And that's what gets me,
Oh God,
it's the worst.
Ah,
especially as someone who has,
depending on how you look at it,
like the most acute form of conditioned like body dysmorphia or orthorexia
possible through a decade of wrestling.
It's just my eating habits are really astonishing.
So there like a German shepherd is like broken into the pantry and eating sticks
of butter on,
on more than more than a few occasions.
But the,
the question I wanted to ask you,
uh,
next is what are the biggest misconceptions that people have about powerful
Tatsu Sulan and I am training myself to say touch Sulan because I've heard
everyone say Satsu lean.
So I'm trying to correct that.
But what are the biggest misconceptions that people have about you?
Well,
do they call him the Big Kettle Bell Guy?
They,
me,
the father of the Kettlebell,
which I appreciate very much.
I did introduce together with my business partner,
I did introduce the kettle belt to the west.
And right now the kettle bell has become mainstream.
But what I'm really all about,
it's above the principles,
the underlying principles of strength training that underlining principles of
power generation.
And it doesn't really matter what modality you use,
whether you use a kettle bell,
the Barbell,
your bodyweight,
whether your armrest and fighting,
lifting rocks,
it really doesn't matter.
So I am not about the kettle bell.
I am about the principles that make us strong.
What I have done is I have reverse engineered the way the strongest people move
naturally.
And I have brought it to the people I've shown to people how to move in this
matter and how to shave off years.
And if not decades of training to progress too much higher then you,
you've worked with some incredible strength athletes.
Would you mind mentioning some of the main,
some of them you've coauthored books with,
but,
uh,
who are,
who are some of the strength athletes that you've collab or a strength trainers
that you've collaborated with?
Andy Bolton.
Uh,
Andy Bolden,
uh,
he's,
the first person to dead lift or a thousand pounds.
He is,
um,
he's an amazing athlete.
He's a very,
very smart trader.
So Andy Bolton,
I,
we have written a book together called the dead,
the dynamite.
And,
uh,
the reason Andy and I have written this project together is again,
and he's very smart trainer and he's particular title that looks exactly like
the Kettlebell swing that I teach.
So it's again,
that fit of the body language.
I have a written a book called easy strengths with debt.
John,
Dan and John is a strange coach extraordinaire.
You would really love introducing dad on the show because he's a beast that is
and who's so again,
he just gets past the fluff.
He goes to the things that matter and then does not have tried to press you then
tries to get the results.
So Dan and I are variation with collaboration with his dad over the years.
Uh,
we have taught each other a lot and our views and strengths are very similar
even though they are colored in some way.
So that's why we have written this book called the easy strengths.
And so easiest strengths was about making yourself strong for your sport,
not making lifting in your priority.
That's what easy strength lives abroad.
And just since you brought it up,
what are some of the things that you've,
you've,
uh,
what would be an example or examples of things you've learned from Dan?
Dan has a terrific concept.
The quadrants,
the four quadrants,
uh,
one grid,
you're going to see the level of development,
the level,
uh,
on the other one you're going to see the level of specialization.
It's really quite hard to explain that,
uh,
over over audio.
But if you look out type in Dan,
John and quadra and since a terrific concept.
So what that allows you to do is it allows you to place yourself today and the
particular quadrant according to your status according to your goals and select
the correct type of training for yourself.
That alone is going to save years of preparation for you.
So that just one of the many things then,
and I have exchanged this little tactical tidbits and details over the years and
I highly recommend that then John has worked to anybody.
Anybody who's an athlete or anybody who thinks of himself or herself as an
athlete.
And I'd love to,
I want to personally give a few examples of just how quickly or how
significantly you can shave off what people assume is required to make massive
gains.
You introduced me to Barry Ross in uh,
Los Angeles and the,
that became the effortless superhuman chapter in the four hour body and I was
able to put,
I'd have to say it must have been between a hundred and 150 pounds on my dead
lift in less than three months.
I mean,
it was,
it was just,
it was crazy.
And uh,
particularly when you consider the inputs or the total amount of time under
tension and,
and actual lifting frequency and time,
it was state.
It really,
I've seen just given that we are cut from the same cloth and that we try to
distill very complex things and,
and use 80 20 analysis and so on.
I've seen a lot of disproportionate outputs for inputs,
but it really just,
it really blew me away.
And the,
the testing of assumptions where in that particular case it's a dead lift based
protocol that's using what many people would consider the weakest range emotion.
So from the floor up to the knees effectively really impressed me in and then
to,
to highlight your,
a couple of the points you made earlier,
the crushing with the grip and the,
the ABS and the glutes.
I recall,
uh,
when I did,
RKC one an RKC too for those people not familiar with the Russian kettlebell
certification one and two a,
which was a tremendous,
a tremendously positive experience for me.
And,
and uh,
encountering a Max plank.
Um,
if I'm getting that,
that is his last name,
right?
Uh,
Mike,
am I getting that right?
Does that Max a big MACs?
Uh,
he,
he was a believer.
I believe that's,
that's the fellow that whose named is,
it's coming to mind.
But there were,
there were a few people,
yourself included who,
uh,
I did not pass all of the tests for RKC to the first time around.
And one of them,
if remembering correctly,
was a cleaning and pressing a kettle bell.
That's roughly half your body weight.
And uh,
I,
I was,
I guess I ultimately made the three attempts and I failed on the first two
attempts and with a few minor corrections just as moving my weight slightly back
towards the heels cleaning,
uh,
with my elbow closer to basically dropping my elbow a little bit lower and then
really focusing on the grip,
I was able to press it.
And the third attempt was felt easy and it was just astonishing.
Uh,
also some of the demonstrations that you've done in front of trainees where
you've taken people out of the crowd and said,
all right,
who's somebody who would consider there,
and I'm paraphrasing here,
but your,
your maximum press x number of kilos and then you'd bring them up in,
in front of everyone in the,
in the,
within five minutes or so,
you'd increase their press by whatever it might be,
five,
five kilos or 10 kilos.
You,
you once mentioned to me in a casual conversation,
I called you for some type of training advice or it might've been via email.
And,
uh,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but you said,
when in doubt,
train your grip and your core is that,
could you elaborate on that?
Because I think it's very,
uh,
it's not advice that many people have received.
Walton,
uh,
there is such a thing as cold.
The radiation.
So the phenomena of irradiation,
what it really means is if you can attract a muscle,
the tension from that muscle is going to spill over to the neighborhood muscles.
So,
uh,
for your listeners,
I'd like to try this,
make a fist,
probably going to feel tension in your forearm.
Now make a tight fist.
You're going to feel tension in your biceps,
triceps.
Don't make a white knuckle fist.
You're going to find that tension is going to spread it into your shoulder.
You latch it back and so on.
Okay,
folks,
you may relax now and,
uh,
the same thing happens.
So certain areas of the body have this great,
uh,
great overflow of tension.
So the gripping muscles or,
yeah,
amongst them.
Why?
In part because they have such a drudge representation in your nervous system,
in your brain.
And as for the ads and us for the glutes,
that has a lot to do with creating your intro abdominal pressure.
So what does this mean exactly?
Visualize your muscles as speakers and visualize your brain as the gadget that
plays the music.
Whatever it is is days,
iPad,
iPhone,
whatever.
And the record player,
it doesn't matter.
And the amount of your pressure,
the pressure in your abdomen,
they dropped Donald,
the pressure,
that's the amplifier,
that's a volume control.
So by increasing the pressure in your abdomen,
it's like you're turning up the volume and vice versa.
So when you're trying to stretch,
when increasing your flexibility,
if you see somebody,
they're trying to do a split and you see
it's a,
the person is creating high intra abdominal pressure and that just increases the
tension of the muscle.
Instead you need to do,
you need to
complete the release and let go and bring it down.
So for strengths would do the opposite.
We have special techniques where you increase that pressure and maximize your
power.
So that's,
those are just a couple of different ways we can increase his strengths.
And that's what you've seen in my certification.
Fyi,
I am no longer with that organization.
So right.
My company,
today's cold,
strong first and sod certification.
That's that same curriculum that you have that you have learned back then.
And uh,
the,
um,
just to,
to touch on two points and then we're going to jump into more training in and
ask about how you would rank certain aspects of what people would traditionally
consider perhaps fitness,
uh,
the,
what would be a good,
what would you,
what would you recommend as good methods for developing,
uh,
the grip and a core or abdomen,
for,
for those people listening,
if they wanted to take a simple protocol and perhaps experiment for the next few
weeks,
what uh,
is,
is there any basic approach that you might suggest for those two things?
It can be done in conjunction with a full body training regimen that uses,
let's say,
kettle bells climbing the road,
so,
so on.
But if it is not,
then what I recommend that you do is you get some grippers.
So the company's called iron mind iron,
mind.com and they carry hen grippers.
One thing you need to understand is these are now those little sissy blessed a
group as you get it at you get at a store.
Uh,
these are heavy duty grippers they'd go up to 365 pounds,
which a couple of people in the world I've done that.
And uh,
they also do have the also do have resources and how to do that.
But even without reading how I can tell you how to train.
So it gets yourself a couple of Gerber's use their charge,
their recommendations that iron mind offers and uh,
start training them in the manner that are referred to as a grease the groove,
the grease,
the groove is a highly simplified training methodology that's been derived from
Soviet weightlifting methodology.
So in a nutshell,
this is what you do throughout the day,
every day,
whenever you feel fully recovered.
So you have to have at least 15 minutes of rest between sets.
You know,
maybe it's 30,
maybe even more is you're going to do as set and you only going to do about half
the repetitions that you are capable of.
So for example,
you've picked up a particular river,
you start squeezing it and uh,
you probably could do it 10 times,
but you only do five and you put it down.
Let's say you later on pick up a gripper that's a little heavier.
Maybe you could do three reps with it,
but you do all one and in this particular manner you accumulate to reps and you
keep going and going and going and everybody tells you that's impossible to get
strong in this particular manner.
Yet science and experience shows that this makes you strong.
These makes you strong as fast.
This makes you a strong in a safe manner and this makes it,
you can apply this particular methodology.
Again,
I go through the group to any strength,
exercise or any strength endurance exercise.
Just to give you an example of its effectiveness.
My father in law,
former marine at the age of 64 started following this routine.
He was able to do about 10 kilometers at that point in several months,
he was up to 20 what he tested and he could not do that mini as a young jarhead,
so a young bucks out there,
you can definitely get this done.
So this is how you guys are going to train your grip with these grippers carry
through with you throughout the day.
You're not going to get sweaty just whenever you feel like it,
just take it out and squeeze.
As for training your abdomen,
there are many different methods of training the abdomen,
but you have to abide by the following the rules.
You have to keep the repetitions to five and under.
No more than five reps.
Anything more than five reps is bodybuilding and you need to make a focus
intention like Nick Leeka focused on contraction as opposed to on reps and
fatigue.
Just to give you an example of the plank,
the plank isn't kind of a fashionable exercise in the core training circles,
and by the way,
we don't use the word core that's thrown first.
Why don't we use the word cord because,
well,
because people will use the word cord.
They do things we don't like.
We don't like it all.
So we just say,
we just say it's action.
And uh,
so the plaque,
so traditionally they would put you in the plank and you were supposed to stay
in displaying for a couple of minutes.
And what's happening is you see this poor person who cannot have an assumed that
proper posture to start with.
And then as fatigue sets in,
uh,
other muscles,
wrong muscles start kicking in,
the back starts arching,
the bus starts shooting up.
And what you're doing is what Greg Cook,
Kohl's,
putting fitness on top of dysfunction.
And what we do instead is if we do a plank who called the hardstyle plank,
we would do a blank for no longer than 10 seconds.
And when you do the plank,
you try to contract everything.
Absolutely everything.
When a,
it showed that,
uh,
everything's hiding this shins,
your forearms,
your neck,
everything,
everything but your neck and face.
Everything below your neck,
you're going to contract.
It's not for folks with high blood pressure,
heart condition.
And that's true for pretty much any type of training.
But for everybody else,
an extremely powerful tool.
So you get down at a plank,
you make fists,
okay?
You can attract your apps,
you can track your glutes,
you can track your entire body.
You pretend that somebody is walking into work by and kick you in the ribs,
which again,
somebody might at at least of my course and uh,
Andrew Bolton and other top power lifters do.
And I've taught this technique.
They swear by this because this is,
they have Donald training for strengths.
This is not just some nonsense that you do cranking out the Reps.
So to sum up your abdominal training,
find whatever abdominal exercises that you like.
It can be the plank youth can be some kind of a set up.
It can be something from your book,
the four hour body.
It can be something from my book,
the hardstyle ABS.
It can be something else that's not important as long as it's a good exercise
that has been recognized that it does work.
And three times a week,
do three to five sets of three to five Reps.
Okay folks,
just remember this.
Three to five sets of three to five reps.
Focus in contraction,
don't focus on fatigue,
dual focus on the reps.
And I promise if you do these two things for several months,
you work your grip in this matter.
You work your abs in this matter.
Everything that you do today is going to be stronger.
I don't care what it is,
it's a bigger deadlift is a tennis serve.
It makes no difference.
You are going to be stronger.
And in the case of the,
the APP,
let's just the,
the,
the midsection and we're working with the plank.
If people decided they were going to keep it simple just so they can remember it
and do three sets of three reps three times a week,
let's just say Monday.
Loves do just three sets of 10 seconds.
Got It.
10 seconds,
10 seconds.
Three times a week.
Yes.
And tried to contract everything below your neck.
Got It.
And,
um,
I just as a,
as further exhibit exhibit a,
uh,
I've always had an,
I'd be curious to dissect this just for a second,
but I've always had difficulty with pull ups.
I have a relatively strong pull from say the floor,
um,
in large part thanks to wrestling and other types of strength training,
but also the barrier Ross protocol when it comes to pulling myself up to a bar
though.
Uh,
I can,
I can use wait for low repetitions,
but I've never been able to do higher repetitions very well.
And I did this greasing the groove,
walking around San Francisco for a few a weeks where anytime I past construction
scaffolding
I would jump up.
And,
uh,
there are enough crazy people in San Francisco.
Fortunately or unfortunately that it didn't really raise any eyebrows,
were like,
oh,
it's just some crazy guy doing pull ups with a backpack,
whatever.
And I would do a two or three bullets and then I'd just continue on my way.
And it was,
it was astonishing.
Uh,
I didn't really test my Max,
uh,
repetitions,
but how,
how much my velocity,
I guess my,
the equivalent of bar speed increased over that period of time.
I mean I really became much,
much more explosive.
It was,
it was just astonishing.
And uh,
but for people who have perhaps trouble with higher repetition pullups,
how would you troubleshoot that?
Well,
to me,
I guess first of all depends on high repetitions mean if it's,
if your is 20 or 25
trickle ups.
Yeah,
let's,
let's use then.
Yes.
That's one thing because if you go beyond that and in Russian,
in Russia they even have specialized competition cause what they do strict
gloves for some crazy insane wraps.
Then training becomes so weird and so state of the art then you better not even
bother.
But most people don't need to do that.
So if you want to be able to do 20 or 25 pull ups,
you can achieve that level purely by training your strength,
which means that you never even have to do more than five or ramps and training.
And just whenever you go out and test,
then you're going to get those reps.
Sure.
Something years in note about strength,
endurance,
the more resistance that you're overcoming in your endurance effort,
the more strength helps.
So what does that mean?
It means that if you're a strong,
that is,
let's say you have a good dentist that's going to help you carry beer kegs to
the second floor.
But on the other hand,
it's not necessarily going to help you,
um,
hammering a nail old day,
if that makes any sense.
Rico's hammers,
light beer kegs are heavy.
So when you're doing at 25 repetition effort,
the weight is significant.
It's so significant percentage of your one rep Max,
so that can be bumped up your religious by,
by getting stronger.
So that'd be my recommendation for people who have a hard time doing pull ups to
start with.
I would recommend,
uh,
start by learning to get tight through their apps.
That's very important.
There was an article a couple of years ago saying that women cannot do pull up
switches out of course is absolutely nonsense.
Uh,
in strong first organization,
we have some ladies who can do,
uh,
you know,
we have a lady in Boston,
uh,
Amanda Perry who can do strict dead hang 14 pullups neck to the bar.
So the way we do pull ups,
there's no kipping,
no swinging pause in between on the bottom and you have to touch your neck to
the bar so she can do 14,
for example.
So she's in my,
I'm the last one,
much better men than most of the men.
And just the way just for those people who have not tried this,
having gone through some of this training with Paul,
if you have just done,
if the difference between doing a strict pullup or what you envisioned to be a
strict pull up where you kind of throw your chin up above the bar height versus
pulling in to touch your neck slowly to the bar.
It is so different as to it's not a difference in degree.
It's sort of a difference in species.
Uh,
but anyway,
I challenge,
I challenge everyone to try it.
It's really challenging.
Well,
it's a,
for people who offer,
people have a hard time just to get started and pull ups.
And again,
that's true for some ladies.
Many ladies.
That's true for a number of gentlemen as well.
A lot of the problem is they're unable to contract their abdominals strongly
enough.
They are enabled to even assume the strong posture.
I remember I told you earlier that I reverse engineer with a strong people do
naturally.
So if you watch a gymnast perform any kind of maneuvers in their rings,
let's say you will see something called the hollow position.
So what's the hollow position?
The hollow position is,
uh,
the body is like your tail talk 10 and your body kind of forms a,
it's like a dish.
Your body looks like a dish pretty much.
So if you want to learn to do clubs first,
you need to master the hollow position.
It's very easy for you to type in it,
type it into your search engine,
the hollow position,
find a picture,
see what it looks like,
and just practices.
Hollow position is Hollow Rock,
listened to action,
says gold to hollow rock.
I explained it into my book hardstyle labs,
but I'm sure you can find it anywhere else.
And so you practice is hollow rock and this hollow rock is going to not only
strengthen your abs,
but it's also going to teach you how to acquire that position.
And that after that you can start working with assisted reps.
And that's a very big difference.
We're not talking about negatives,
we're not talking about four straps.
We're talking about assistance reps,
assistant reps.
So what's the difference?
The differences and assisted rep feels like a moderately challenging rep that
you do on your own.
So your training partner or your trainer is going to push it in your mid back
and enable you to do that with some degree of difficulty,
but definitely not make his struggle.
And when they've done a study on young gymnast years ago and the Soviet Union
and they use this type of methodology that cold it,
artificial controlling environment where the partner allows you to do a perfect
repetition but in a way that doesn't really kill you.
It doesn't make your struggle.
They fall in that the speed with which the progress was absolutely remarkable.
So practicing your hollow rock and don't forget your grip and then start three
times a week with the help of your training partner do let's say it's three to
five sets of three to five reps of assistant assisted pull ups.
And I just want to reiterate again,
the low reps are key guys.
If you want to be strong,
you need to keep your reps at five and under
and at at five reps are under is what you're really working on.
Sort of the it's,
and that I'll get out of my depth and into yours pretty quickly,
but the sort of neural pathways in their recruit,
the recruitment of motor neurons and uh,
sort of firing capabilities and so on.
Pretty much you were going to have,
you're going to have a high level of neural adaptations and uh,
you are all sort going to build some muscle as well.
So you're going to build a high threshold motor units as well.
But not,
it's not a bodybuilding protocol.
You will build some muscle,
but it's not really the end Dan goal itself.
So,
uh,
you were trying to also,
you're trying to avoid the fatigue.
You're trying to avoid the burn because whenever I start experiencing the burn,
that's from something called the hydrogen ions,
that bleeds to whole lot of problems for you.
So one of the problems is it interferes with the command that your brain's sends
to the muscle to contract.
And another problem that it creates these hydrogen ions,
literal or destructive.
So if you leave them around the muscle for too long,
they really start destroying your muscle.
So just keep those reps under.
And a five,
three to five,
don't worry about getting bulky,
are not going to get blockades.
It's not going to happen.
And a approach your training as a practice.
So this is another very important point,
Tim.
I hate the super important point.
No,
I'm glad you're bringing this up.
I hate the word workouts.
The award workout does not exist in the Russian language.
We talk about a training session or would talk about it a lesson we never talked
about a workout.
Just sync of what does the word working out,
what is it,
what do you envision?
Sweating and grunting and
the CLSC.
Let's see how much I can punish myself and draining myself.
So the goal is not to get stronger.
The goal is just to get,
get worn out.
And there are simpler ways of doing that.
Drawing up the mountain.
Okay.
So no,
the idea here is practice strength is a skill and as such it must be practiced.
And if you approach it in this matter,
not only you're going to get stronger so much faster,
but you get a truly enjoy your training process.
Training.
It should be something that should be enjoyed.
No,
I this,
this,
this ring,
so true to me.
And it was really a revelation just coming from the masochistic,
uh,
world of the few sports that I practiced in a certainly did not get to a world
class level,
but competed on a national level in a few different sports.
And the,
the mind shift from a depleting your reservoir or reserves as much as possible
to identifying the skills and practicing them even if it,
if you feel better at the end of a workout than at the beginning,
was really a huge shift for me in a few places.
Uh,
certainly in strength training,
I think that,
uh,
you know,
Barry Ross's protocol was eyeopening in so much as just like you mentioned,
put a hundred,
I think it was around 120.
This is all detailed in the four hour body.
So I'd,
I'm losing the specifics,
but about about 120 pounds on my Max deadlift through them,
through the full range of motion,
not just the range in which we were practicing,
uh,
in a short period of time and gained fewer than 10 pounds of additional muscle.
And you probably had judge your training.
Loved it.
Oh,
is it was just amazing.
I mean,
felt on fire.
partially because you're,
you're blowing a fog horn into your nervous system's ear when you do it.
Uh,
but the,
the,
the other area,
and I think this,
this is such a fantastic principle that applies to so many different areas was
in the world of swimming.
And,
uh,
some people might recall if they followed my stuff for a while that I was not
able to swim a lap in a proper pool,
uh,
until I was in my thirties.
And what,
what really shifted the mindset completely was going from swimming workouts and,
and hiring coaches who viewed it that way,
to looking at total immersion where they really focus on the skill of
deconstructing the biomechanics of swimming,
challenging the assumptions of how swimming's taught.
And it became this really joyful,
wonderful experience.
And I was able to go from a biscuit zero lapse to sort of 20 laps per practice
in less than 10 days.
So it's,
it's such an important shift and I'm glad you brought it up,
which,
which kind of leads me to the next,
uh,
the next question that,
and it's about prioritization.
So when people think of fitness,
uh,
particularly nonathletes,
I think that there tends to be very scattershot approach and there's a paradox
of choice challenge that they have where they're,
they're fed a lot of recommendations from many different people and they have
strength at,
let's just talk this strength,
not necessarily muscle gain,
but just getting stronger.
They have hypertrophy.
So increasing there is a muscular size,
for lack of a better description,
endurance,
flexibility.
How would you rank these in order of priority and why?
As long as the person has their required mobility and symmetry,
the priority is always an health did.
Priority's always strengths.
Strengths has to be at first.
So the first step that you do is you assess your mobility.
You find a specialist who can do that.
Fms would be,
fms would be recommendation of mine.
Very Kooks FM as functional movement screen functional movement screen is going
to find out how mobile you are and also how symmetrical you are.
So as long as that is dialed in,
that is in place,
you have to get strong and strength is the mother quality of all physical
qualities and that's not a statement by me.
That's a statement by my fist I'm about to be the father of fertilization,
one of the greatest sports scientists ever and greater strength increases your
performance in absolutely everything so you can see of course,
okay,
of course,
yet being stronger as get them help you and let's say punching somebody harder,
lifting something,
but how is that going to help me?
You find let's say a triathlete.
How's that going to help me find that marathon runner?
It is going to help you in several different ways.
One is the perceived level of exertion is going to go down.
Several years ago in our regions did a very interesting study where they put a
elite endurance athletes,
some more bicyclists sound were runners on at pure strength regimen does four
sets or four reps of heavy squats.
It's about as strength is against and in the end of the study,
not surprisingly,
all these guys were stronger.
They could jump higher and so on,
but they were not impressed with that.
That didn't matter to them.
What did impress them is there ran faster,
there are times their race times went down because strengths just makes,
enables everything else.
If you were trying to,
let's say,
lose weight being stronger is going to help you do that because you're going to
have,
uh,
you can have,
have a bigger furnace,
you're going to train yourself much harder.
And the exercises that are fat loss exercises,
so it really doesn't matter what it is that you're trying to achieve.
Strength is the number one attribute you need to address.
And that's why my company's called strong first.
You know,
I love,
I love that you,
one of the things that I love about you Pablo,
is that you see what you mean and mean what you say.
And I,
I just,
it,
there's a,
there's a degree of clarity that I,
I envy and uh,
I might include it for people,
but the,
when we did our sound check,
I asked you to do,
to give me an answer so we can test the audio of what you had for breakfast and
what was your answer?
Coffee.
And that was it.
That was the soundcheck.
I love this,
the simplicity.
Now,
speaking of simplicity and also a sort of undoing the confusion that a lot of
people suffer from,
what are,
what are the most counterproductive myths or misconceptions about strength
training that come to mind?
Well,
the number one team I guess is the idea that you have to go to failure every
time you trade.
Right?
And I can tell you one thing that is so good to weightlifters.
I have done a very thorough analysis of the student weightlifting methodology
from through the sixties through the eighties the Laura days.
And I've found that they typically did one third to two third of maximal
repetitions per set.
So what does it mean you flood stayed this,
you're using a way that's your 10 rep,
Max Tendonitis.
All you could do if you push yourself very hard,
they would do three to six consistently.
Now you'd probably ask yourself,
okay,
I'm not a weight lifter and what does this still get stuff from the eighties
have to do with today?
Well,
two things.
First of all,
even though a person who is not at lifting athlete,
it's not going to train exactly as a weightlifter a power lifter.
Nevertheless,
the methodology has to be derived from the sports because these are specialists
strength sports,
so it they just have to be adapted to your needs.
Second of all,
the this particular is so good methodology is still superior to this day.
This is very interesting,
but if you keep hearing about all this new world records set in the sport of
weightlifting,
well if you compare the world records today to the world records of the 80s you
will see then in most cases the records today are inferior to Rutgers in the 80s
how can that be?
They accuse people of doing drugs and they changed weight classes twice since
the 80s.
Of course.
It's so wonderful.
I'm so happy that today nobody does drugs anymore.
Just terrific.
If you look at,
if you look at the lifts performed by sort of,
you have lift her,
you would have provided by neon in 1980 at the Moscow Olympics.
This lifts have never been exceeded.
These lives have never been approached.
So this particular methodology does work extremely well.
It's still the best methodology period.
Later on in the store we had power lifting team adopted this methodology for
part of the thing with tremendous success that dominate and uh,
these same particular methodology has been adopted to bodyweight training,
Kettlebell press is and so on and so forth.
So it's the same thing to come up life for everybody because this is principle
based training.
So the major misconception is that you have to go to failure.
So that's if you just overcome that and if you make it a habit to do one third
to two third of the repetitions that are possible and do more sets.
Instead you are going to make much grid to progress.
You're going to do much safer and folks are going to enjoy your training.
And how do,
how does the approach shift if your focus is a maximal hypertrophy,
if you're after maximum hypertrophy is volume.
So they figured out in the Soviet Union that there's a direct correlation
between volume and a hypertrophy.
She just pretty much have to do more sets.
You're going to have to do more sets in there,
like 60 to 70% of your max range and a whole bunch of sets of five and six does
many of them.
And your rest periods might be compressed a little more.
But that's it.
If you do that,
do this a couple of times a week.
Many sets of five or six don't want to worry about how many,
just just keep going.
Don't kill yourself,
enjoy yourself,
uh,
eat more,
you're going to get bigger.
It's unavoidable.
It's just as simple as that.
I've of course I've,
I've spoken to with,
uh,
with fans and written about the APP,
the applications of to failure training for primarily hypertrophy just because
you're,
you're doing so much with the sarcoplasmic him and maximizing the sort of a
cellular volume,
uh,
that the,
the challenge is not so much the training with hypertrophy.
It's the eating.
Uh,
it's just,
I mean,
you really,
you feel like the,
the,
the Japanese hot dog Kobayashi after awhile,
it's just waking up in the middle of the night to eat meals and whatnot.
It's,
uh,
that,
that's by far the most punishing aspect of,
for me at least
it is dumb.
It is.
And uh,
any tricks there,
nobody knows.
Also,
Yeah,
there are a couple of tricks,
but there,
no,
I'll mention them in a second.
Yeah.
Nobody does know exactly what happens in the cellular level when you try to
stimulate muscle hypertrophy.
Anybody who tells you that they know they,
you know,
it's just a speculation.
At best.
There were a number of theories.
Some of the theories are more credible than others,
but the fact is we still do not know.
And what makes this Soviet,
uh,
weight lifting methodology of the eighties so spectacular is that was a purely
empirical methodology.
They tried to explain what happens in the southern level,
but they didn't try too hard.
It was pretty much a trial and error that would analyze the training logs of
successful lifters and successful competitions.
They analyze this data,
they made recommendations and there's kind of a chicken and egg.
Where does this start?
Scientist watching what the best lifters do,
what the best lifters divided scientists telling the best lifters want to do.
It was kind of both and they kept narrowing down,
narrowing down,
narrowing it down.
And this is how it works.
But we still don't know exactly what happens there.
What is your,
I want to,
I definitely want to touch on the,
the tricks for not making yourself nauseous all day when you're trying to,
to pack on pounds of muscle.
But before that,
what is your favorite pet theory,
even if its speculative at this point,
what is your preferred theory?
Uh,
for muscular growth.
Okay.
If I think about passing cause theory makes most sense to me.
And according to this theory,
when the muscle comes,
the contraction comes to an end or close to an end.
When you have depleted the creatine phosphate in the muscle,
that's the primary stimulus for hypertrophy according to him.
And again,
what could that possibly,
well,
how could that possibly do in if the muscle contractions stops not as a result
of mounting acidity.
And that's very,
very important.
But as a result of there's simply not enough creatine phosphate,
supposedly the,
uh,
cross bridges no longer can really disengage properly.
So supposedly,
right?
Crossbridges you're talking about the mindset.
That's right.
Yep.
So bowls ugly.
This is what terrorism apart to Bozo,
that's what causes the microtrauma that makes us satellite cells do their thing.
So that's one fair.
The credible explanation.
I don't know if this is true or not,
but training in my experience that,
but that since got,
but that's when it goes approach to training.
Were you going to hit it pretty hard?
Uh,
this set would probably be about 20,
30 seconds in duration.
If you're trying to target your highest potential motor units and then you're
going to have to stop and you have to rest a long time between the,
between the sets.
So this,
it does make a lot of sense.
There was another theory that works fairly well with it.
Uh,
professor Victosa,
Leanna according to him,
the role of creating a phosphate here is once you deplete your creatine
phosphate and you do have a lot of free period,
which is pretty much byproduct.
What that does is makes the membrane of the cell permeable to the hormones,
anabolic hormones.
Very interesting.
So what's hill?
Yanno says there are four prerequisites to muscle hypertrophy.
One is obvious is a,
that's the presence of amino acids.
The second is the presence of anabolic hormones,
which obviously has to do with the capacity we are and the current system,
but also your training as well.
Training stress,
does it seem to do that.
And third is the presence of Free Kreatin as the,
again,
the same thing that free creates and it's a lot of recruiting.
This forums when the muscles pushed hard but not before it gets a city.
And finally the fourth one is,
uh,
the presence of hydrogen ions.
Not,
not for too long.
So I get hydrogen ions.
It's again,
it's uh,
something that you get out of muscle contraction animals or contraction.
And the service that they do for muscle hypertrophy according to see young of,
is just like the free creating.
They make the membrane permeable to the hormones.
So then,
uh,
then what happens is this hormones,
which are pretty much messengers,
they go into the cell and as they go into the cell,
they had good,
the whole process of transcription,
translation,
you know,
protein synthesis going the also the very interesting element of a single young
of theory and Celiac was methodology and against something that sits well with
me.
I'm having observed training.
Effective training is very long recipe or as between sets.
So it's Juliana fricking mance five to 10 minutes of rest between the sets and
that at rest has to be active.
So you pretty much have to move around.
So you don't just,
you don't just sit,
you just move your way of you arms.
You got to shake your muscles,
you shake your legs,
you walk.
And that's opposed to good tread of the clear out the hydrogen ions as quickly
as possible because having them there briefly as good,
having there for too long,
it's not good because it literally destructive.
It's a charged particle.
That's what it is.
And um,
so they're walking or are they on stationary bikes on like an Arrow?
Diamonds.
You don't need a stationary bike,
you just pretty much want to walk there.
Or there's a particular type of relaxation exercises,
Tim,
we'll call it fast and loose exercises the old Russian athletes do.
So pretty much what the are is if you may remember my Kettlebell certification,
I had people standing kind of shake out the arms and legs,
right?
So you're just pretty much shake your arms and legs and you just walk around.
That's,
that's pretty much what you do.
So that's,
that is a silly Yanas Siri,
which also seems to make sense.
Notice that in both cases where there's protesting that goes there were civil
Yana ups,
you are going to push yourself much closer to failure to rep Max.
So when you're training just for strength,
you don't need to do that.
You just do one third to two thirds of your maximum reps when you're trying to
train for hypertrophy.
Yes,
you can do just simply more setbacks and we'll sets,
but sometimes you just have to push yourself harder not to fail.
There's still but harder and Juliana full.
So it has the most fascinating slow twitch fiber protocol as well.
I'd like to tell your readers about it because there are a lot of misconceptions
about training the slow fibers.
Well if you think about slow fibers as well,
which most people associate with endurance.
Yeah,
exactly.
And they do have endurance.
That's true.
But there are also people think,
well they're thin,
they're weak,
they're small.
And why should I do that?
Why would any self-respecting Paul are athletes,
you know,
demeaned himself,
training a slow car.
So,
and uh,
Giuliano has a very different point of view on this.
First of all,
if you look at back in the six in some studies done in the 60s,
if you compare the strengths of your slow fibers and fast ones,
uh,
they are just as strong for the same cross section.
So which means that if you have a bundle of slow fibers that's as thick as your
finger and you have a bundle of fast fibers that's as thick as your finger,
they're equally strong.
Just this lower bundle is going to have more smaller fibers,
but it doesn't matter number one.
Number two,
because their velocity of contraction for the fast fibers can be 20,
40% higher.
For this slow fibers,
the presumption is,
well,
I need to move fast.
I can't afford that.
So,
but see was work has found out that even in sprint,
50% of the output is provided by slow fibers.
And he says,
even though in vitro,
that may be true that these fibers are contracting faster,
but in Vivo,
in real life and sport activities,
you're not really going to go so fast.
So that's advantages.
No longer,
no longer valid.
He has put experienced sprinters on a training protocol that hypertrophied there
slow fibers and these sprinters improve their sprint 400 meters on every Trump
10.9 seconds to 10.7 just form just from this slow,
fast,
slow fibric hypertrophy.
And there is additional benefits of hyperledger for your slow fibers.
Something we can discuss a little bit later if we talk about,
if you choose to talk about endurance,
is these slow fibers count pre equipped with Mitochondria,
which means they have a lot of endurance.
So for other types of athletes that can be very beneficial.
So Seattle Yacht has this fascinating training protocol for training,
for hypertrophy of slow fibers.
So here's how this goes.
He says the biggest problem that you have is typically the people that just try
to go and burn them out.
Well,
but all that does again,
that just the gig comes to an end because of the mounting acidity.
That's not the right stimulus right there.
You want to make sure that you exhausted creatine phosphate and get the free
creative flowing.
So how do you do that?
You create a collusion.
So he would have you do a occlusion.
Yeah.
It means basically shut with the contraction,
prevents the blood flow,
right?
It's a constant tension.
Would bodybuilders would call constant tension.
And what you would do is you would do,
let's say squats,
you go a little bit below parallel,
you go a little bit above parallel and you're going to slow,
the timeframe is 30 to 60 seconds that the duration and uh,
you have to counter failure with close to failure.
Now this is again,
this is what's really fascinating after that,
and this is what's so different from the traditional slow twitch training is you
have to take that same five to 10 minutes active rest because he says if you
don't,
that mounting a city is going to mess everything up.
And on one day a week,
typically you would do four to nine sets in this matter and then three to four
days later you do a second day where you do one,
two,
three sets.
So that's a protocol.
One more time,
super slow movement.
No rest,
30 to 60 seconds in duration,
one day a week,
four to nine sets,
three to four days later.
One,
two,
three sets,
five to 10 minutes of rest in between active rest by the way,
active rest and also mean and work in different muscle groups.
That's very fine as well.
And just to tell you how effective this protocol is,
he put a number of athletes,
experienced athletes from different sports on the WHO knew how to squat on a
back squad protocol using these music thing,
these types of reps and sets and so on.
And in eight weeks these guys increased more than added,
more than 25% of their back squat.
Holy Crap.
Yeah.
And you realize these guys were not these guys,
we're not your typical American college subjects.
You know the guys were very fast thumbs,
you know Facebook people,
no,
I'm talking,
I'm talking about athletes
and what percentage of their one rep Max were they using for these 30 to 62nd
sets.
Cause that's a,
that's a challenging micro range of movement.
The typical guidelines,
you have to find it for yourself because that depends on your boss,
on your fiber composition.
Typically it's about 30 to 60% for your lower body and tend to 40% free opera
body.
So why is the difference and the difference is,
uh,
is determined by the fact that your opera bodies more fest bridge.
So if you look at an average person and every,
each person's going to have about 70% fast twitch fibers in the upper body and
lower body,
but 50,
50.
But uh,
so you have to use a weight relatively speaking for the upper body to stay in
that timeframe.
I see.
Got It.
That is it trial and error?
It is just trial it out.
No,
of course.
And what would people,
what would you suggest they Google or search for to learn more about this?
Uh,
nothing I'm afraid,
but I think that's,
and that that means don't search for quote nothing.
I'm afraid that means you can't search for it.
They listened very carefully to what I said.
They should have no problem doing that.
I can give you a couple of exercises.
Other exercises that you can do.
So for the lower body,
uh,
you can use the back squats or you can use the front squat and a for the upper
body you could use something like the diamond pushups for the triceps and what
you need to do is you need to adjust the difficulty based on adjusted elevation
elevates your hands.
If you want it easier,
elevate your feet.
Do you want to make it harder?
But again,
the idea is to come to failure.
It's rooted,
so did to 60 seconds and a for the push up,
you're going to be working in the new range so you never get to come to lock
out.
You know,
if we're going to come to the bottom,
you're going to slowly keep working,
keep working through that mid range.
If you want to do this for the upper body is probably the best idea,
would be some kind of a rolling machine.
And again,
you're going to be working it through the mid range or curls,
I hate to say it,
but she has curls.
Sulla Yan of Sila Yacht of has been extremely successful with athletes from very
diverse sports.
Uh,
he's,
uh,
worked with national team for judo,
Sambo,
uh,
full contact cut out day bicycler racing soccer and these guys who have seen
terrific,
terrific results from this.
So,
uh,
you guys may want to give it a try.
That's,
yeah,
the,
the fascinating,
the most unexpected aspect of that for me is the,
the five to 10 minute rest sets.
That's really fascinating.
And I should also,
I'd love to underscore one thing for people and please correct me Pablo if I'm
getting this incorrect,
but a lot of folks think about the burn as being a product of lactate or lactic
acid,
but it's actually a byproduct or a side effect to primary effect of the hydrogen
ions that you were talking about.
It is.
Um,
and I think that that has a lot of,
there is some swelling and nerve endings are,
yeah.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
it really folks,
that really doesn't matter.
The only thing that you need to realize is this,
on this particular training protocol you go for this barn is burned,
is needed.
The important thing is that burn is over after 30 to 60 seconds.
And then you try to good tread of as fast as possible.
And for other types of training,
if you're trying to train for strength,
you want to try and to avoid the burden altogether,
the burners,
the burn is your enemy.
I've to two,
uh,
two questions on the details here.
The first is if the free creatine,
I guess that's just free creatine in,
in serum,
uh,
although I could be wrong on that,
is one of the stimuli,
uh,
that,
that produces the,
the training adaptation,
can you accelerate that or even catalyze it with supplemental use of Creatine
monohydrate for instance?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Okay.
And then second question,
uh,
is related to the,
what some people have called the golden era of steroids,
which was the 80s.
Right?
So the,
I guess what I'm very curious to know is why have the why of the Soviets changed
their approach or what has caused the,
um,
what is,
what has prevented them from attaining or surpassing the records of the 80s and
understood obviously that athletes are still using many different types of
performance enhancing drugs.
But,
um,
what has changed or and why did they change it?
Tim,
I think Dan John has said it really well.
It works so well.
I got bored with it and I stopped doing it.
Yeah.
And a will before,
shortly before their death.
Uh,
not,
you know,
in the last decade,
both vice eidetic see if who was a great champion and a archives.
You but I'd be off was a great champion and a sports scientists,
they criticize these practices very,
very heavily.
At least see me advise you of who,
uh,
also has done the same thing they just said,
basically you guys are barking up the wrong tree right here.
So I just think that people are trying to get fantasy.
It's funny.
That's what's happening in Russia is probably reflecting that whole trend,
western trend.
That's,
and that seemed to call new Amania.
People love the New People just absolutely love the new there.
They're forgetting that what stuff that will work.
It's worked much better.
You could consider the results.
There was all sorts of period back.
Then the same thing.
You can look at the power lifting methodology,
uh,
the ulcer going back to the 80s,
the classic American power lifting methodology,
the classic cycling as exemplified by lifters like Ed Coan and Lamar gant and a
systematized by Marty Gallagher.
Again,
people are saying,
well,
we have better training methods these days and they're showing you a different
numbers in the squats and the bench press and so on.
To which I say,
well,
in the squat and the bench press,
it has become impossible to really compare apples and apples because it will
these crazy shirts and it's usually people are wearing exactly,
but in the deadlift you are still seeing,
look at the record tables,
the record tables and number of the death of trekkers are still set back in the
eighties and nineties and there is still sitting.
These are old timey historic correctors and even the advancement of some
assistance gear for the deadlift and advancement of the longer bars.
We'd be at bars and so on yet improved some pools,
but still many of this record is still do stand.
And uh,
the 80s is a fascinating era for strength.
I wrote a blog a little while ago that I call it forward to the past.
It was inspired by the upcoming 30th anniversary of the movie back to the
future.
And if point and the point I made in there,
and look,
you know,
if Marty Mcfly,
I want it to travel there.
Plenty of reasons to travel to today's Day,
but looking for strength advice that he would have been much better off staying
home because it's so hidden up with lifting cause the dollar to the 80s the
American power lifting methodology of the eighties this to or remain superior.
And that's not something you can argue.
Yeah.
Even from the deliver,
not familiar,
perhaps,
especially for people who are not familiar with powerlifting,
I think would just be fascinated by,
by Ed coan.
What was it?
He pulled a,
Oh God,
I'm blanking here.
Nine oh one probably.
That's a little button I will add.
It has body weight.
That was 20 years old.
Yeah.
Sanity
ad has said Ed has said some workloads to a hundred world records in and he has
competed in weight classes,
you know,
so many different weight classes over the years.
So he also had a remarkably injury-free courier.
Just really remarkably
his hips gave him,
I mean he's had,
he's had hip issues since then.
Do you think that's a result of sumo style deadlift?
I doubt it very much.
I mean deep squat,
if you,
if you talk to somebody like Greg Cook,
if you'd talk to somebody professors to it and my Gill,
you will find that deeper wide squads could pop.
Probably lead to some problems.
Sumo deadlift.
It's extremely,
extremely unlikely.
Very interesting.
And one of the things that,
Tim,
sorry to interrupt you,
how many people do you know who don't sumo dead lift anything heavier than a
newspaper and have to go get,
get their hips?
No,
exactly.
And this is actually something I was going to bring up,
which is when people see the [inaudible] of the world of the bodybuilders who
get cancer and they go,
oh my God,
you know,
the,
the steroids cause cancer.
And it's like,
well,
you have to look at it in the context of how many people out of a thousand would
get cancer,
whether they're in the gym or injecting steroids or not to really have a fair
assessment of the causal factors.
Right.
So,
so your point's well taken,
the thing,
the origin.
Gotcha.
I'll interrupt you though and I will say one thing.
I'll keep interrupting any of these guys.
Many of these guys who competed at a very high level in the eighties and the
seventies are very healthy and doing extremely well.
If you look at Gallagher himself,
he's right now,
he's in his sixties.
He's a very strong,
he's very surprised,
fully healthy hikes in the woods,
you know,
every day.
If you look at,
uh,
weight lifters,
forget the 80s.
Let's go back a little farther.
A little bit of poop fed.
Yeah.
He was,
uh,
his,
Soviet German.
Uh,
he was a Olympic champion in weightlifting,
had the age of 37 and that's something that's never been incredible replicated.
Absolutely.
It is incredible.
Today he's somewhere in his mid eighties,
and uh,
every day as part of his training regimen,
he does jump squats with 200 pounds,
90 kilos.
So he goes rock bottom of the squat and jumps up.
And that's the guy in his mid eighties.
And in fact,
you look so good.
So some journalist came to interview him.
He said,
excuse me,
sir,
may we speak to your dad?
That's amazing.
Wow.
Something to aspire to.
I've been at,
just on the,
on the weightlifter point,
uh,
I've been spending time with an amazing gentleman named,
Jersey Gregorich.
I'm not sure if that rings a bell,
but yeah,
he is a very nice man.
He's a Polish or accomplish this year.
Very accomplished,
uh,
rolled class weightlifter,
I think primarily in the master's division,
but he's,
I'm speculating here,
probably in his mix,
mid sixties.
I'm spending time with him and he can still,
you know,
throw,
I don't,
I don't know the exact weight,
but the a two to 300 pounds over his head in the snatch,
no problem.
That was a jersey is still going to do a full splits.
I,
he is IX.
He is amazingly flexible.
I haven't asked him to do any vandamme type stuff for me,
uh,
but his,
his ability,
his head,
his hamstring flexibility,
which of course is much more than hamstrings.
But what I perceive with a lay person would perceive as hamstring flexibility
just blows my mind.
It's,
it's amazing how flexible this guy is.
Uh,
so it's,
it that's,
um,
I'm very interested in the long game,
so,
but increasingly interested,
you know,
the older I get,
I'm 37 and I can't,
I'm certainly not going to be winning any,
a Olympic gold medals anytime soon.
And weightlift
my father to cop Barbara Lifting at the age of 71,
he's 77 today.
Uh,
he dead lifted 413 pounds without a belt.
And a,
he said,
you know,
several American records in his age group and overtraining for five years.
So he put on 20 pounds of muscle.
If you look at my father looked at him from the back,
you will think that this guy's gotta be in his forties and he looks like a
wrestler.
He is just massive.
And a stu McGill when he examined him,
he says he's got,
he's never as soon as such as career development of a 70 Rome and uh,
he started when he was 71.
Would,
would you consider the,
uh,
and please disagree if this is not the case,
but if you had to pick one movement for strength,
longevity with the deadlift,
be that mood,
that movement,
or is it not possible to choose one movement?
How would you try to answer that question?
If you were to choose one moment,
Tim?
Yes,
I would choose the deadlift or I would choose the Kettlebell swing.
Obviously the Kettlebell swing is not something you couldn't compete in and
something you're not,
it's not going to give it that same satisfaction was lifting heavy weight.
But,
uh,
those are the two main full body exercises,
the full body expressions of power that will go such a long way for you,
for lungevity strengths,
just the quality of life
are there.
What are the biggest mistakes that people make with the deadlift,
whether that's technically or in,
in programming,
what are the biggest mistakes?
And not,
not asking you to repeat things you've already said,
but is it,
are there any things that are top of mind that a,
well,
Tim,
I think they're very big mistake is because they think,
okay,
I have big tops things from the floor.
This looks so simple.
It's not an Olympic lift,
therefore it's very simple.
So just start filing on place and start training they'd done as a very technical
lift.
And even if you're just a recreation lifter,
you owe it to yourself to learn to deadlift correctly.
So that's,
that's as simple as that.
So I say that's,
that's a primary mistake and that mistake goes for every exercise that people do
out there.
Yeah.
And I would highly recommend people check out your book with,
um,
and now I want to say,
uh,
with Mr. Bolton.
Dynamite.
Yeah.
Really a very,
very dense,
uh,
shifting gears just a little bit dense and the best way possible.
Um,
no,
no fluff.
Uh,
I'd love to shift gears and just ask you a few questions about,
it's sort of your philosophies and your thinking,
not the,
not so much,
uh,
the,
the highly specific training questions.
But when you think of,
for instance,
the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind for you?
Okay.
Tim.
I am fortunate enough to know many successful people and I think that what
separates him from the rest is,
uh,
does she have strong first Eric for a heart,
he put it very well.
He says balance with priorities.
Balance was priorities.
So Eric,
yourself and many others are fortunate to know they exemplify success for me.
And the how do you,
what is the best way?
What are the habits that you've observed that allow people to have balance with
priorities?
What are the,
the things they do that other people don't do?
Or maybe the things they don't do that other people do.
Well,
I think one is calm.
Okay.
These people are calm because people who are hyper,
they get so trapped in their reactive mode.
They get too trapped in the everyday minutia of their work in their existence.
So they just do not pause and they do not sync again.
Eric has a great quote from the Vietnam era seal which says calm is contagious.
It's contagious.
So when the person is calm that he or she has the time to meditate,
reflect,
sad,
their priorities and uh,
send the balance.
Yeah,
that's certainly the holds true from what I've seen.
And the opposite of course is true.
Hysteria is chasing the tail.
Absolutely.
Chicken little,
this guy's falling.
Everything is urgent.
It sounds like the Internet in a nutshell right there as well.
Uh,
uh,
what do you have any morning rituals?
What does you,
what are the,
what are the first,
what is the first hour or two of your day look like?
Typically I like to ease into my day.
I will get up early.
6:00 AM typically and my wife and I will just have coffee and read the newspaper
and make small talk and I really take my time.
I pointedly Rita favor not watch TV,
not to get any kind of electronic news or radio.
I really appreciated the calm of print because whenever you're watching TV it's
just the latest news breaking news and it's again that same tail chasing
after that.
If I,
if I decide to the train with kettle bells,
I'll go to the beach and do that.
If I do not do that this morning,
I'll just still go to the beach for half an hour.
What time?
That'll probably be about seven o'clock and I will take a dip.
I'll meditate a little,
I might stretch a little.
So it's again,
it's a time to time to be composed.
After that,
it's a time to do creative work.
So I will either write or I will do research and when I do that I very pointedly
have the email down.
So my whole email application is down.
If I need to use the Internet for some research,
you know,
the browser will stay out,
but not the email.
And My colleagues know to call me if they have something urgent.
And uh,
not a lot of people call me because I have my business card only has my email.
So that's good.
Does it have your email and then it says please call a virgin?
No,
he doesn't know my,
obviously my colleagues do have that.
So and when I write I will sometimes change the environment.
I'd like to go to a coffee shop or go to a park or something.
And I do have a particular methods when I,
when I write.
So I will just select some topic and I work in this topic and as soon as I hit
the wall and this topic,
I just switched to something else.
I had never find the right at writer's block.
I just absolutely,
I just have a lot of different things,
a lot of different projects,
chapters,
articles,
books,
whatever,
going at the same time.
And I'm very flexible about it.
And also do let my Luca Brasi evolve and sometimes they evolve in a very
unpredictable manner.
The naked warriors started out as a book for strength training in the field for
the military.
And then it evolved in a sort of a manifesto for reverse engineering,
the body language of the strong.
So I just kind of allowed that to happen.
Towards the end of the day,
it's a make a call,
make a call with my coworkers,
take care of some business and with my wife and you know,
pretty much relaxed.
Read some first reason nonfiction that or read some fiction.
That's a pretty standard day.
I like my days.
I like the sound of your days to the uh,
the,
do you listen to music and if so,
what type of music,
what are the most frequently played songs or albums on your iPhone or,
well,
my,
my music tastes are,
I like the ying and Yang kind of like stuff in the middle.
So on one hand I enjoy 1980s,
heavy metal I like accept aren't maiden Saxon do's are my favorite bands.
On the other hand,
I will listen to Jackson Browne.
Carla Bruni [inaudible] time.
So in my opinion,
music has to be either,
you know.
Yeah,
it is.
exactly.
Seriously,
it's like a performance is the same,
the art,
a physical performance as the art of turning on the switch and shutting it off
for maximal strength,
you have to turn to allot for maximum flexibility and endurance.
You have to turn it off.
And for a lot of sports is that ability to join it on and off,
on and off,
back and forth,
tension,
relaxation.
So I do like these extremes in my music.
Right?
So you're either you're either Vivaldi or Penn,
Tara and no,
nope,
no pop music and all this stuff in the middle has no rights to exist.
And,
uh,
when you're writing,
are you writing?
Do you write on a laptop?
Do you write?
And if so,
do you use word or some other program?
Uh,
or are you writing in a journal?
How are you jumping between these various articles that you're working on?
To my right and ward.
And,
uh,
what I do is I have a very big Cuellar,
a type of organization of data in my mind,
in my mind,
I have many different shelves with many different projects and many different
research studies and so on.
So I can kind of see in my mind what connects with what I see,
the pattern.
So I can go back and forth.
And I really think that,
uh,
the computer does enable me to do that so much easier.
And I'm generally not a fan of technology,
but I have to say that the word processor,
it's one piece of technology that I have a very big fan,
I think on the page.
I don't think in my mind,
I think in the page.
Yeah.
That's,
that's something that I've,
I've heard from a number of good writers is that they,
they have to write to clarify what they're actually thinking.
It's another thing to day form the thought and put it down.
They use the process of writing to clarify their thinking.
Uh,
do you,
do you have a private journal or anything like that?
No.
You do not.
Okay.
And,
uh,
just since,
I love talking about this,
but I won't take too long.
A recommendation that really was a game changer for me is using a program called
scrivener,
a in of word and a Scribner's is as it sounds,
uh,
what that allows you to do it,
it was originally designed for a movie scripts I believe for screenwriting.
And what it allows you to do is have all of your various documents which would
each otherwise be a separate word file in a table of contents on the left hand
side of the screen,
which you can move around and modify and put into folders,
which I uh,
I've used for are all of my,
my last three books.
And then you can look at two different pieces of writing on the right hand side.
So it all typically have is a folder that's all research documents and,
and I will have a split pane on the right side where the top is,
what I'm working on,
what I'm actually writing.
And the bottom right is the research document.
So rather than having a million windows open with different word documents and
as you've probably experienced,
once you have enough of those open,
eventually it just craps out on you and jumps off the cliff.
Ah,
I've,
I don't think I've ever had in however many years I've used it,
scrivener fail on me and it's because it strips out a lot of the bloat.
But you might really,
I don't think I'll definitely try it.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a fun program to play with and I don't have the mental,
uh,
I have too many plates spinning at once in terms of,
of articles if I'm working on a larger project like a book.
So scrivener helps me to codify that,
which I find very helpful.
How do you change your,
do you change your typical routine on the weekends?
Is there anything that you do differently on the weekends to decompress or
otherwise?
Not a lot.
Go to church,
go out,
go for a hike with my wife Julie.
But otherwise,
pretty much every day I tried to have,
uh,
at balance work and balance of family and balance of recreation and a balance of
self improvement.
Speaking on,
on the last point,
self improvement,
uh,
what are,
what are things that you're currently trying to,
uh,
or would like to improve about yourself?
Well,
above myself that would be private,
Timmy.
I think that it's just maturity.
It's just us girls just between us.
I think that over sharing is one of the major malfunctions of the modern world.
So,
uh,
I think I'm going to keep these ones for myself,
but I'm going to tell you what I'm trying to improve professionally.
Okay,
that's fine.
I have,
uh,
as I mentioned again,
I have been able to dissect the very successful weightlifting methodology of the
sixties through eighties,
uh,
which is extremely complex methodology and I've been able to bring it down to
the underlying principles and codify it and write up hug rhythms.
So what I'm,
what I'm doing right now is trying to bring this very sophisticated,
very amazing system of training to regular people who just want to get stronger.
So I am in this refinement phase.
Got It.
And so just touch on that just as a segway,
I'd love to talk about flexibility because I get a lot of questions about
flexibility.
I don't consider it my area of expertise,
so I constantly refer people to your work.
But uh,
I'd love to hear you talk about where flexibility fits into the picture or when
it does.
Because I think for me and for other people,
there's a lot of confusion around mobility versus flexibility.
Uh,
one of the questions I get most often for instance is,
uh,
how do I get to the full side splits?
They want to go between the chairs,
like Van Damme and you know,
is that,
is that a,
a a worthwhile goal?
Is it a terrible goal?
And this is a lot coming at you at once,
but how does,
how does flexibility fit into the picture or not for what types of people?
Okay.
Well first of all,
let me tell you about the goal of this split.
Whether you,
if you choose to achieve that,
it's achievable.
I will tell you a great success story.
He's one of the strong first instructors and he is truly a product of the
system.
The gentleman's name is Steve freebies and he's a music professor.
He was severely injured.
His lower back was herniated,
very bad.
He spent eight or nine months in bed and Percocet.
It was very bad.
And then he decided to become a man,
decided to train seriously for strength,
for flexibility training like a real athlete after getting the proper medical
clearance and so on.
Of course.
So fast forward to today,
see free these who is a 59 if I'm not mistaken,
he holds a number of American records for is age group in the dead lift and he
Douglas without a belt.
And Steve freebies,
59 year old man who used to have horrendously messed up back,
can do suspend the size,
please just like find down.
So,
uh,
you've exists,
he's out there thing that you were too old or too whatever.
You just got to get to shape up.
All right,
so touching on the,
all right,
I will raise my hand.
I'm one of those disease.
Uh,
if,
and I've,
I've had this,
I think there are many to do's that are,
there's the,
they're the nice to have things than the must have things.
And for me it's been at least a decade,
maybe 20 years where I've had the suspended sides splits on the to do list and
it,
it just gets,
it gets renewed.
You know,
it's kind of like a car insurance.
Like I renew it every year,
but I never really make any use of it.
So,
uh,
we'll deal with that will get you there.
You know,
it's whether it's a worthwhile goal or not to pursue you.
Obviously there's the obvious just because it is their right and there was no
way up judge Doug kind of go,
somebody climbs to the mountain and somebody,
uh,
somebody learns to do a side split.
Is that something that she needed to do for your performance outside of several
sports like taekwondo or gymnastics?
No,
you really don't.
Is that going to improve your wellbeing?
I do have to say that this sense of freedom that you have on your hips when you
consistently can do a full split,
it's really pretty awesome to have that feeling of freedom and the hips.
You can only know that freedom if you also have known what not to have it,
if that makes any sense.
So I will periodically,
you know,
for a while I kind of would not treat tooted to serious.
They take some time,
you know,
stretch very lightly,
kind of stay,
might keep,
maybe it's 70% and then I'll just make the push again and bring it back.
And I always really enjoy that feeling of freedom.
So that's,
it's,
it's a decision though.
Let's talk about this mobility,
a flexibility of business.
Let's talk about how people should proceed about it.
So Mobility,
pretty much,
we were talking about the full range of motion in the joint when,
uh,
the length of the muscle is not an issue.
So let's use an example of a full squat.
Okay.
So if you're in a full squad,
uh,
you know,
not a whole lot of officers are preventing you from hitting that range of
motion.
So there may be a possibly that you need to just pretty much get your joint
moving smoother.
So what does that mean folks?
It just literally means,
uh,
just doing a whole bunch of squats very slowly and not very slowly,
just slowly and building up progressively range of motion.
Uh,
I'm also,
I could admission,
I'm also the famous Soviet scientists who was a kind of a health guru.
He would perform this movements every day.
He would perform a hundred squats every day and a hundred other other things.
If you're not up for doing that,
you just simply hold on to the doorway.
So he just unloaded yourself partially.
You shift your weight more to the heels to make it easier on your knees and you
start squatting and don't go to pain,
you know,
be very progressive.
It goes deep as you can eventually go deeper.
Just do multiple sets.
And the same thing is true really for pretty much for all the other joints.
But obviously they have joined stats.
That's a big one.
And everybody needs,
everybody needs this type of training.
I like a very simple,
uh,
joint mobility protocol.
Obviously you can make this as complex as you want seriously and may people
have.
But like in my book,
Kettlebells,
simple and sinister,
that's my latest book.
I give this protocol where they're just,
just a couple of different exercises you do.
One exercise you do is you just kind of a move the extra step,
move a way to round your head in a circle,
a halo,
loosen up the shoulders.
And other exercise you do is a very particular type of squat.
Got a prion goblets quad.
That's a terrific exercise.
So you can do search online,
prying Goblin squad just for people.
I remember the first time I heard you say that I embarrassed myself at the
certification because I thought you were saying goblins squat and I asked you
what a Goblin squad is.
So for me,
it is a goblet,
uh,
like drinking out of a goblet squat,
the name by and John,
and it's,
it's a terrific type of a squad that's literally squad for the people.
See,
the problem with the squat exercise is most people are don't know how to move
well,
they're tight and you try to put a bar in their bag and they just cannot do
that.
So the goblets quad is kind of a squad for the people that then developed.
And uh,
the prying that is added to that is something that really allows you to increase
your mobility and flexibility.
So,
uh,
what you need to do when you trying to get,
get your flexibility increase.
Let's say that an mobility,
let's pick any exercise that you're doing,
any kind of a stretch that you're doing,
whatever it is.
So there are certain rules that you need to abide by.
And uh,
I call these the three s so use your strength,
find space and spread the load.
Use Strength,
find space,
spread the load.
So what does that,
so what does that mean exactly,
Tim?
Well,
let's use an example of the squad.
Using strength for the squad means pulling yourself down into the squat.
Instead of just dropping yourself using example of the split,
instead of trying to drop yourself down into the split,
you're very actively pushing your feet out,
like you're trying to spread the walls apart.
So spreading the walls apart,
that means you're using strengths,
find space.
So what does finding space finding space mean?
Just pretty much kind of a prying and moving your body into the position and
trying to find more space in the joint and also try to loosen up the Fascia.
That sheet,
that fiber sheet around your muscles.
It's a very good analogy would be trying to pull a post out of the ground.
So let's say you're trying to pull a pollster that grown.
It's a concrete poles.
You pull on it hard and it's not going to come out.
And I can tell you because I have tried then down in southern California,
I know that was not a golf vandalizing parking lot more back in the past we had
a house and uh,
we bought a house and there was some,
some things in the bag that I wanted to demolish.
So I'm trying to pull all this concrete posts so I tie and nylon rope to this
post that attach it to a crow bar,
get a nice strong sumo deadlift position.
I pool,
well what happens is the nylon rope rips and I do a back flip into the pilot
dirt because I'm very smart.
I do this two more times.
And then my wife Julie walks by,
she says,
you know,
you could just kind of a wiggle it around pride.
I said,
oh,
that's right honey.
So the same thing is really with your flexibility.
So let's Tim,
let's use the,
let's use the example of the straddle.
Let's say you're trying to get the straddle instead of simply trying to force
yourself down.
So straddle meaning sites buts a side split,
but maybe lying on your stomach or maybe sitting up doesn't really matter either
way.
So he looked like a frog on its stomach.
Pretty much.
So what you're trying to do is,
what you're trying to do is not just force your way in one direction,
but you're trying to kind of a pride to him loosen up in every direction
possible.
So let's say that you are,
uh,
let's see,
you are resting in your forums,
so you trying to get into this,
this straddle.
So your first pushing your legs out,
but then you're also kind of tilting your pelvis back and forth.
Then you're going to try to kind of wiggle your butt's side to side.
Then you will try to turn your body one way you can to try to turn your body the
either way.
So pretty much what you're doing is you're taking advantage of the fact that
your Fascia,
that covers your muscles,
it runs and all sorts of different directions,
kind of like plywood.
So you need to loosen that up and a lot of different ways.
So if you keep going in different directions all around you will progress to
those goals so much faster.
So you strength find space and spread the load and again,
spreading the load just pretty much means that you are not just trying to focus
in that particular joint so you to be spreading it all around and we're like
[inaudible] is the absolutely absolute relaxation and impatience are the two
things that are absolutely fundamental.
If you're trying to get a high level of flexibility,
like a split,
you see you get a recommendation,
let's say,
oh hold the stretch for and they'll give you some duration,
30 seconds or whatever.
Like how did they arrive at that number?
I have no idea.
Just somebody decided,
well that sounds like a nice round number,
let's recommend that.
But what you're trying to do,
it's disturbing how much of the world comes about that way.
All it's like how many glasses of water you're supposed to drink it.
It's just the same thing.
And so you know,
hold the stretch for 30 seconds,
but the fact is you are trying to wear out your stretch reflex.
You're trying to leg the muscle,
relax.
And depending on your fiber composition,
depending on your mental,
state,
emotional state training,
history,
injuries,
tree,
they can take different times.
So just don't worry about it.
So you just get in this position and you kind of a pry a little bit for awhile
and then you just relax and when you relax,
we try to breeze through that tight spot.
When I say breathe through,
I'm saying,
just listen to my breathing.
You completely release the tension.
Totally.
If you do this,
which is pretty much what most people do when they're trying to stretch,
you're tightening up the muscles.
So you just have to complete the lead.
Go.
You have to be patient and you have to spend,
you have to spend good half an hour,
40 minutes.
And this type of practice said day.
If you really are serious about reaching that level,
how long,
I'm sorry,
about 30,
40 minutes.
But even if you don't,
well,
there are ways of doing it faster to him,
but that involves isometric stretching.
And that's a little bit more technically involved to talk about here and the
show.
But,
uh,
even if you did not pursue this extreme flexibility,
go even if you just want to be flexible to whatever level you want to be
flexible and understand that the idea of relaxation breathing and patients are
absolutely fundamental.
You have to be patient flexibility training is not something you should ever do
when you're in a hurry for some appointment.
It's something you should save for the end of the day.
Let's say you're watching some TV show just and go and stretch,
or you're reading a book.
One of my colleagues,
Dr. Mark Chang,
a strong first senior instructor,
he has these beautiful side splits.
The way he worked up to east side split is she would just sit and read a book in
a straddle on the ground and then at some point whenever he felt like he could,
he just tried to spread his legs a wider and that's it.
You go back to reading his book.
So they see acquiring flexibility.
It's an exercise in patience.
So if you do not have the patience or if you do not have the time,
I suggest to just give up.
And the,
uh,
the isometric,
just to touch on that is,
is that a variant or press the same thing as p and f,
the,
uh,
pretty much sequential certificate contractions and uh,
and release.
Yeah.
So here's how this works in a nutshell.
Imagine that you are,
let's say that you're stretched out far and it feels like,
uh,
I,
I cannot go any farther than muscle.
It cannot get any tighter.
Then you slowly contract that muscle slowly.
So important for safety and you'd build up the tension and you hold that tension
for awhile and then you release that tension.
The important thing is again,
release.
And when you have released,
you will see this contrast.
So in a way you kind of a climb from the fire into the frying pan,
it's still hot but not as hot and you can eke out just a little bit more range
of motion.
So these isometric contractions can be added to any type of stretching.
And,
uh,
the idea of the very important thing and bogged them as you need to make them
steady,
do not make them jerky in any way.
The only thing that bottom that sudden is that release,
otherwise steady,
steady,
steady.
And when you're,
when you're holding the contraction,
and this is hard to quantify,
but uh,
as a guideline,
what percentage of maximal contraction is that?
You know,
there are various,
there are various methods.
Some of them attempt for you to bring the attention to a very,
very high level.
Gradually still very gradually but very too high level to the point where the
muscle literally shuts down something called Golgi tendon organ just fires
mostly just goes,
ah,
that's an advanced technique.
It takes,
takes a lot of practice.
Uh,
you can go or you can just go for a very steady tension of about 30% and just
try to stay there for pretty much as long as you can handle it.
Just the important thing is that the tension doesn't diminish,
you know,
whatever.
When you feel like the tension is about to diminish whatever level that you've
chosen,
then you just release and then you pry it a farther prior to before,
uh,
mark,
Chang has one of the most impressive Turkish getups I've ever seen.
Very impressive.
As if for people who are not familiar with that move,
you could,
you could certainly do a search and see some examples.
That is a very,
very,
very technical move.
Uh,
and the Turkish get up.
The beautiful thing about the Turkish get up that somebody like yourself who is
a minimalist when appreciate is you get done so much with so little.
It's one of those amazing all around want to stop shop exercises and some food
for thought for people in general.
When you think about training earlier we talked about where he straight offs,
what to do in the program is training is just like a budget budget for a person
who has a regular paycheck.
So you have to decide,
am I going to buy a couch or I'm going to go on vacation,
am I going to get in debt and do both?
I'm going to buy the glue,
the good couch and not go on vacation or buy a cheap couch and take a short
vacation.
You see my point.
So there were a lot of choices,
a lot of trade offs and these trade offs have to do with both.
Your time,
but also where the capacity of your endocrine system,
your endocrine system can only handle so much training and all these different
types of training that they are added up.
And plus he also have the stresses of your life and so on.
So whenever you're deciding on what it is that you do for your exercise,
you have to identify really what's important.
It's tripped and on essential and uh,
make compromises and sacrifices somewhere.
Yeah,
true.
For so many areas.
I want it to come back to something you said about oversharing earlier and the,
uh,
cause it was the,
the,
the flaws or the,
the dangers of oversharing and malfunction,
the malfunction even better.
I've oversharing,
so that's kind my,
my business model I guess.
But
the,
uh,
the I'd love to
is my opinion.
I'm not judging.
Oh,
no,
no.
You can feel free to judge.
I think.
I think that oversharing is a problem also.
But,
uh,
I'd love to hear your thoughts on what Americans could learn from,
perhaps the culture you grew up in,
the former Soviet Union or vice versa.
Because I personally,
and this is not meant as a slight at all,
I have so much respect for so many people in the former Soviet Union.
Uh,
I've,
most of my observation has been in the,
in the sports arena,
a sports arena.
I mean,
looking at people like Constantine Constantine off or Dimitri cloak off or just
these,
these amazing specimens.
But I haven't very tough time when I meet some people from the former Soviet
Union socially with,
uh,
getting through the cultural differences.
And I'm usually,
I don't usually find that hard unless there's a lot of vodka involved.
Um,
but well,
that's,
that's the social lubricant to need to a,
you just need to drink more vodka.
What,
what,
what could Americans
learn from,
uh,
from the culture you grew up in or vice versa?
Okay.
Well,
first of all,
I'm speaking about this Sobeys coucher.
I'm not talking about the current culture,
the Post Soviet college here because unfortunate,
this is my observation that oftentimes when different countries learn something
from America,
they choose to learn,
not that things that are worth learning,
right.
I really would like to see for Russia to learn about a free enterprise,
about a fair competition,
about freedom.
And unfortunately the things they are learning and are not,
these are like reality to me.
That's what they're learning and that's,
that's not unique to rush it.
That's,
that's pretty universal around the world for some reason.
Instead of getting the best from America,
people are just sort of getting the Las Vegas version America
and what people can learn,
what Americans can learn is they can learn to limit their choices.
You mentioned earlier and the paradox of choice,
they was embarrassed Schwartz book,
right?
That's right.
It's a very good book.
I enjoyed the book very much and I think that is,
I think that is very true.
When there's so many choices to exercise,
these choices are difficult.
It takes a lot of processing power.
There was a great,
uh,
moment in a Phil Moscow on the Hudson and old film with Robin Williams where he
walks into a,
an American grocery store and he sees coffee everywhere.
He says,
coffee,
and he just passes out.
So what is very difficult in this country is exercising the choice because
options are just so many and choices are difficult.
And in fact,
you will find out that a number of eastern Europeans who have failed to
assimilate with failed to make the life in America are the ones we just have a
hard time making choices.
They're used to for a lot of choices being made for them.
And there was obvious downside to that in terms of freedom.
There was obviously an op side of it because there's,
there are fewer distractions.
So you,
uh,
personally,
not youtube,
but the listeners,
you need to figure out how to limit your choices then made these choices and
stick to them.
The Constantino and the cloaker.
When these other Russian athletes,
you mentioned these guys do not train with 360 degree bud's queasiness,
God curl bench.
That GBC in the typical gym is guys have the basics and they just hammer just to
wrap.
So the hammer and the basics and the,
I'm a big admirer of the free enterprise system.
Unfortunately,
as much as that's worked in so many fields and industries is completely failed
in,
uh,
the exercise industry,
the fitness industry,
because it's constantly chasing its tail tail with a novelty,
the new,
the best or whatever,
and as a fad,
that just goes away again.
But the simple fact is certain things just do not change.
What I think also,
I think Americans could really learn is they could learn from themselves.
That can learn from the past.
I have a great,
uh,
idealized image of America that I did when I was growing up and that came from
my favorite film is in the magnificent seven.
It's interesting that they showed that film when my dad was in the service and
there was Kim health first and then I saw it many years later.
They showed it again and I was just very impressed with this ethics that you
could see.
They're these very strong,
so if we're aligned,
people who don't a waste towards,
who do not get stuck in a part of hierarchy,
who should a ride into the sunset,
I think just very powerful.
I think if America we just a little bit more reconnect with what makes his,
makes it great,
it wouldn't have to search elsewhere.
Uh,
we can talk about American exceptionalism and there is such a thing as American
exceptionalism because no other country has that same sense of freedom,
has the same opportunities and that same spirit of everything as possible.
No other place.
So even people who go out and start criticizing America,
that's usually,
it happens because of anime.
That's really all it is.
So maybe let's just go back to the older times.
Maybe some of them didn't even exist.
The old west,
whatever it is,
where just people,
I had the pride in being pioneers.
The pride in just getting ahead or let's even look Tim,
lesson one,
look in the fifties or sixties like today,
where do the brightest young people,
what did they end up doing?
They ended up designing APPS,
right?
Well,
in the fifties and sixties they design space ships.
So the dreams were just so much bigger.
And right now,
who,
who was this hot new APP?
Ooh,
golly.
Gee Martha.
So let's just try to go back to what made this country great to a grand vision
and not just petty little APP stuff.
Who are some of the,
the people for you,
whether current day or,
uh,
hundreds of years ago or more,
who exemplify the best of what America has to offer?
If people listening,
we're looking for role models,
role models to revisit or to try to emulate.
Who would you put on that list?
I'll say the founding fathers.
Ben Franklin,
definitely
there.
So many great people in American history.
They're worth emulating.
There's the great generation of the World War II,
these really quiet people.
We just went and got the job done and uh,
then twine and complain about the lack of opportunities and life is hard.
Then we're having it so tough.
There are many.
I have,
uh,
and just,
you know,
even people who are just,
even people who are younger,
I have a good friend named stony.
Stony was a marine.
He a father of Vietnam and just stone.
He's just such a great person who is such a positive outlook on life.
He just uses a true American.
You will not hear and complaining.
He thinks that America is by great things.
And that's what seriously this is what disappoints me as an,
as a naturalized American because I think America is so much bigger,
so much better than it's than it has been.
So just look back into it.
It was before.
No,
I,
I'm of course born and raised here,
but very much feel the same way.
And it's been uplifting to me though to see that although the,
the,
the kids building apps as some of which are very rural changing I think,
but many of which are not and are very trivial.
Uh,
if,
if we look at Apps,
it's just the new software applications and mobile devices.
That is the new computers.
There are people changing the world.
But there,
there's also been a resurgence of,
of people aspiring to be like Elon Musk for instance,
who is building spaceships.
Uh,
and uh,
that,
that's been really reassuring to me in some ways.
But,
uh,
the,
the Ben Franklin example I think is a great one.
And for anyone who hasn't read the,
the Walter Isaacson biography of Benjamin Franklin.
It's a fascinating,
fascinating,
uh,
picture of,
deep,
uh,
very capable but also hilarious figure.
Uh,
I wanted to just in,
in,
uh,
in closing
a few more questions,
uh,
but the first is how do you personally limit your choices to avoid the coffee,
coffee,
coffee experience and the,
and the distraction.
How do you,
what are some ways in which you,
uh,
you contain those,
those choices in life
to him?
Professionally?
I use this,
I use the same technique that you use for voting.
I remember that you mentioned that you don't like following the current current
affairs before you vote.
You just talked to a number of people whose opinion you respect and who old the
way,
who delivered the way you do.
So I do the same thing and training pretty much.
So when I do,
and I do research,
most of my time is spent reading the classics.
So we had tests and studies and uh,
once in a while,
either rise up on periscope and I'll talk to several people I respect in the
industry and as what's going on,
what's new.
And they will just brief me on that most of the time,
frankly,
nothing's going on.
So this is an example of,
this is an example of that.
My technique.
I am very ruthless about limiting my communications.
I am very protective of my time to write.
I'm very protective of my time to read.
And,
uh,
that's what it,
no,
that's a,
I think this is a really important topic and I appreciate the answers.
And I also encourage everyone to think about how they can create their own
choice,
minimal lifestyle so they can preserve their creativity and unique abilities for
the storage.
We need to,
we need to,
we need to teach people around us,
be,
uh,
to understand that not to over communicate.
It's again,
it's an interesting modern phenomenon that it's a play by play.
Everything has to be a play by play.
It's like,
you know,
kids in the car.
Are we there yet?
No,
we're driving,
we're on route.
And uh,
no.
So,
uh,
this has been really fun,
Pablo.
I really appreciate the time.
Uh,
how,
what,
what are you up to focused on currently?
Where can people learn more about you?
Uh,
where would you suggest people look to,
to learn more about,
uh,
the things you work on?
Thank you,
Tim.
My company's called strong.
First strong for his.com is the website and,
uh,
we are about changing lives,
making the world a stronger place strew through strength.
So we teach various skills through courses,
certifications and so on.
So just we stopped by@strongforhis.com and I also,
uh,
recommend you pick up a copy of my book,
Kettle Bells,
simple and sinister.
And I can assure you that this book definitely fits with the spirit of this
conversation.
It was absolutely nothing fluff,
no fluff there whatsoever.
And,
uh,
just,
just to,
to,
to also add my,
my own 2 cents related to my direct experience.
Uh,
Pablos methods,
your methods,
Pablo,
uh,
and those that you've distilled from all of the mines and practitioners,
the operators that you've researched and observed a really do work.
So,
uh,
for,
for those people who know me,
I obviously conduct hundreds and thousands of various experiments and we might,
my house right now just looks like a,
a laboratory slash pharmacy.
There's so much crap strewn about related to all the various odd,
uh,
you know,
human Guinea pig stuff that I'm doing.
And I,
I've really run the gamut and,
and tested so many things available out there and in a world that tends to
complicate to profit,
I think you really simplify to results.
And so I commend you for that and I've seen tremendous,
tremendous transformations in my own life,
thanks to a lot of your advice.
So I really encourage people to check it out.
And this was,
this was a,
so,
uh,
hopefully sometimes we can do with that around to in person buds.
Uh,
thank you so much for the time,
Pavel.
And until next time,
thank you to man power to all right.
Same to you.
This episode of the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is the world's largest online marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years including to get cover concepts for the four hour
body,
which went on to become number one New York Times Number One Wall Street
Journal.
It was a huge ship and here's how it works and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions.
You can see these book covers and so on at 99 designs.com/tim whether you need a
logo,
a car wrap,
a webdesign and af,
a thumbnail,
a tee shirt,
whatever.
You go to 99 designs.com you describe your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas and designs and drafts.
You have an original design that you love or you pay nothing.
It is fantastic.
I have used it.
I have mentioned it before,
including in the four hour work week as a resource.
Check it out,
99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
and if you use that link,
you'll be able to see what I've done on the platform.
You will also get $99 as an upgrade for free,
which will get you more designs,
more submissions.
So check it out,
and until next time,
thank you for listening,
okay?
Okay.
Okay?
Yeah.
Okay.